Harry Potter and the half-blood Prince
we are getting closer and closer to the
end of the Harry Potter reviews and
closer and closer to fantastic beasts
and where to find them which I'm super
pumped for before I get into the review
I just want to say that my copy of the
cursed child is resting on the legs of
Batman I'm just I'm just proud of that I
don't I don't know
so half-blood Prince was once again
directed by David Yates and this was
also the first film in the franchise for
a while to be rated PG in this movie it
starts out with Harry still trying to
get a date Harry is still very much so
in the middle of puberty and Dumbledore
comes along and ruins everything
man what a terrible wingman one of my
favorite things about the half-blood
prince is that harry has become very
accustomed at this point to things not
going his way so a large portion of this
movie is him kind of like yeah I get it
life sucks I understand he still has
that love of magic and that off for it
but there is a part of him that's grown
colder that's grown darker because every
time he gets slightly ahead he's always
knocked back so Dumbledore takes Harry
to recruit Horus played by Jim Broadbent
who is someone they really need to teach
at this school who has some reluctance
about it this guy has crucial memories
of Tom Riddle's youth now Voldemort and
Dumbledore tries to use Harry to get
closer to Horus so they can get that
information from him because Dumbledore
is positive that this very crucial
memory can help them defeat Voldemort
so half-blood Prince is a very subtle
movie it's very quiet
there isn't much happening in this movie
it's definitely the most uneventful
Harry Potter film that isn't necessarily
a bad thing though because this film is
really in my opinion the very first
adult Harry Potter film even though
order of the Phoenix and Goblet of Fire
and Azkaban got darker than the last
ones this film does feel like it's more
aimed at adults because there is a lot
of inaction there's a lot of mystery
there's a lot of dialogue there's a lot
of character building and there's barely
any magic battles at all it's a very
character-driven movie and that's a big
compliment for a movie like this that
appeals to a young demographic because
Harry Potter has a franchise
has that rare quality that very few
franchises of this type have that of
appealing to adults and kids also some
very important things happen towards the
end of this movie for Harry Potter's
life that of Dumbledore's death at the
hands of Severus Snape and so this movie
absolutely had to build that
relationship between Harry and
Dumbledore
because order of the Phoenix didn't
really explore it at all because
Dumbledore was pretty much avoiding
Harry for the majority of that movie so
this movie really had to build those
characters so when those really
important scenes come at the end of the
movie they have emotional weight and
half-blood Prince definitely did that
there are aspects of this movie that do
bother me though after Harry becoming a
teacher and teaching all the kids magic
and the big magic battle at the end of
order of the Phoenix this movie is at
times a little slow paced and so there
are parts of this movie despite all the
character depth that do drag but my
biggest issue with this movie is that it
took out certain things from the book
that would really have helped explain a
few things that happen in this movie
like at the end one Dumbledore and Harry
just show up in this cave with this
liquid the Dumbledore has to drink
that's very poisonous and it's very
difficult from the drink it's a very
intense scene it's very scary it's very
thrilling with the in farías that come
out of the water it's very cool but how
did they get there how to Dumbledore
know to get there certain visions that
are needed to explain things were
omitted from this film and so some
things actually don't quite always make
sense and things don't tie together as
well as they should
unless you read the book but gratefully
just like the other films even when they
get dark this movie retains a great
sense of humor that allows us to
remember who these characters really are
like Harry when he decides to drink his
liquid luck that was given to him by
Horace he just gets so excited
everything's this great he's happy which
is so funny because for the majority of
the movie he's on the absolute opposite
side of that spectrum emotionally so to
see him go to that height was really
entertaining this movie also explores
the relationship between Harry and Ginny
more so than the others there's a great
scene where Harry gets up when Ginny
walks into a room and it was just it was
adorable if I'm sitting I'm gonna stand
up the next time my wife enters a room
it'll make her feel good try it people
with significant others stand up when
they walk into a room and show them
respect I bet you you'll have a great
day there's also a scene in this movie
I've always laughed at for
two reasons one it actually is very
funny and two I'm a huge fan of a
certain anime what is this which a MOBA
track and bolt I just can't help but
love the fact that Harry Potter just
said Dragon Balls it makes me all tingly
in my nerd organs so Harry is eventually
able to convince Horace to tell him what
he needs to know by using the memory of
his mother it's a very touching scene it
was really heartfelt and he finally
figures out what it needs to know and
through him and Dumbledore they go on a
search for the Horcruxes devices that
are linked to Voldemort's very being and
if they can destroy all of them they
destroy Voldemort and that's where we
get that really intense scene we already
discussed but towards the end of this
movie this is when it gets really really
sad because Draco is a lot worse than he
used to be he's no longer just a bully
he's getting really close to Voldemort
and he has that evil brewing within him
but he's not sure if he has to act on it
yet and Severus steps in and kills
Dumbledore but there is a sense a little
hint that they have some sort of
arrangement and you're not entirely sure
this entire finale is just painfully sad
with the death of Dumbledore it feels as
if hope has been completely lost at
Hogwarts and Harry knows he has to go
out with Hermione and Ron to find those
Horcruxes and destroy Voldemort and the
very last scene with the three of them
talking seeing the Phoenix fly away was
truly touching Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince is not my favorite
movie it is a bit uneventful as I said
it does take some liberties with
removing things from the book that would
have helped by putting those things in
the movie but still it's a very
entertaining movie with great character
depth and it's also a very mature movie
I'm going to give Harry Potter and the
half-blood Prince of B+ next up guys is
the beginning of the end Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows Part 1 look
forward to that guys you're the best
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
you